are agreeing to not take this further
legally that's what a settlement
agreement is about and that is perfectly
reasonable and there are often cases
where it he said she said she said she
said he said he said and nobody can
agree and there's no proof and so we
can't tell if it's right or wrong so the
two parties will agree to settle that
settlement money is for the damages and
it is to not or it is not to take the
case further legally it is not
to not speak about a trauma that has
happened to you now I think Maria will
back me up here is that it is the
statistics in terms of people who make
vexatious claims and want to go to the
press to talk about what has happened to
them are minimal
the reason that people are now going to
the Press every week it seems with with
you know scandals and and breaking their
ndas and speaking about toxic work
environment environments is because they
are desperate